la mort vous y pensez souvent elle fait
partie maintenant de votre quotidien ou
elle est la chassz au loin justement ah
je chasse jamais non
non ce que je voudrais vous demander en
première question c'est justement est-ce
que la maladie le cancer vous a
transformé oui oui même on pourrait même
dire qu'à certains jours même assez
souvent je remercie de que ça me soit
arrivé comme ça en tout cas alors je ne
sais pas
si je ne sais pas si à un moment donné
euh c'est pas c'est pas la mort qui qui
qui qui vient vous chercher si c'est pas
la vie qui se révolte c'est-à-dire bah
c'estàdire que à un moment donné la vie
en a eu marre que je la
cherche elle a eu envie que je m'occupe
d'elle un peu donc de vous donc un petit
peu de moi quelque part mais autrement
et vous pensez maintenant que vous ne
vous êtes pas occupé de vous pendant
toutes ces années oui c'estàd que en
développant un ego démesurés
dans ce métier être absolument attentif
au paraître c'està-dire être ne vivre
que dans le regard de l'autre on finit
par par oublier qui on est peut savoir
tout à fait être soi c'est vrai que je
pense que oui un moment donné oui c'est
c'est très difficile d'arrêter de jouer
un rôle on joue un rôle en permanence
vousvez vraiment ce sentiment là d'avoir
joué un rôle pendant de nombreuses
années oui ave des avec des fragments de
sincérité comme comme on a des fragments
d'amour des fragments de bonheur des
fragments voilà ant le masque est tombé
je sais pas j'essie en tout cas qu'il
soit qu'il soit bien tombé toujours vous
avez voulu fuir le quotidien la
monotonie oui j'ai toujours dit non j'ai
toujours dit non tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps alors peut-être avec
une
obsession un peu exagéré probablement
parce que ça m'a amené à cette frénésie
puisque je ne trouvais pas puis que à
vouloir trouver la perfection évidemment
à moi d' la perfection dans votre vie la
femme idéale parce qu'on va y venir dans
votre der dernier livre he vous en
parlez énormément hein de la quête de la
femme mais moi je pense que c'est ça le
le souci de l'homme c'est cette femme
idéale qui dort sous ses paupire et
quand il ouvre les yeux il a jamais
celle évidemment qu'il a qu'il a
visualisé ou qu'il a rêvé et je crois
que si on regarde mieux euh avec plus
d'attention avec plus d'amour surtout
avec plus de de lumière dans son propre
regard bien sûr qu'elle est là bien sûr
qu'elle est là et vous avez rencontré
l'amour oui j'ai rencontré des femmes
bien sûr et j'ai eu des des des femmes
que j'ai aimé certes mais euh
je je cherche toujours à savoir ce qui
est vraiment à part à part l'amour avec
un un a immense qui est celui de de
l'amour absolu je ne sais pas trop on
est tous en train de chercher c'est tous
pour tous une une même quête mais je me
su plus ou moins effrainé plus ou moins
effrainé oui plus ou moins effrainé
c'est c'est tout ça moi même c'est qu'en
reparlant de la jeunesse reparlant de
l'enfance des choses ressurgissaient
très très fort des souvenirs extrêmement
extrêmement perturbant déséquilibrant
même donc j'ai voulu décomter tout ça et
et puis des histoires me sont revenues
de de d'autres rencontres faites dans la
marine particulièrement c'est vrai pour
revenir à votre enfance donc très jeune
finalement vous êtes engagé sur le
bateau la jeune d'c j'avais envie de
voyager parce que je voyais arriver les
cargot de de de de l'autre côté de
l'horizon je j'avais des parfums
nouveaux il y avait des langues que
j'entendais et ça repartait et
probablement mon imaginaire avec eux
donc jour ou l'autre j'ai dit non il
doit y avoir quelque chose derrière
l'horizon de tout à fait extraordinaire
tout à fait merveilleux c'est comme
certains montagnards qui gent une
montagne dire c'est peut-être mieux
derrière l'autre colline et puis
derrière l'autre colline bon et et j'ai
eu ça toute ma vie ce qui a été un drame
effectivement j'ai toujours cru que
c'était mieux là-bas parce que je n'ai
jamais surgardé ce qu'il y avait à côté
donc très très vite cette vie qui
m'était proposée au lycée technique
avoir quoi comme av venir je sais pas
travailler ce que j'ai fait d'ailleurs
un moment donné travailler en usine je
sa jeis pas du tout envie de ça donc je
suis parti dans cette marine mais ce qui
m'a évidemment passionné c'est la c'est
la vie des hommes moi j'étais un
adolescent j'ai à peine commencé mon
adolescence j'avais oui 14 ans j'étais
pas très en avance en plus comme garçon
euh je n'avais pas connu de dame encore
donc j'étais
vierge vierge de tout
et je me suis retrouvé sur sur sur ce
bateau avec des hommes vous alle voir il
y a eu l'école mais ça l'école ça a été
assez assez bref et puis me retrouver le
plus jeune le plus jeune matelot de la
marine française et vous avez cette vie
parce que vous auriez pu la détester non
non non non non j'ai j'ai trouvé ça
assez fascinant quelqu foois détestable
mais tout à fait fascinant mais attendez
j'avais une chance là encore bon j'ai pu
choisir mon bateau puisque j'étais sorti
premier donc j'ai choisi la gendar parce
qu'elle faisait le tour du monde donc
j'ai fait deux fois le tour du monde
donc avant 20 ans enfin avant 19 ans
même j'avais fait deux fois le tour du
monde et vous dites dans votre livre un
marin dans un port à deux objectifs
trouver une femme et le quartier des
bares alors c'était pas mon objectif à
moi c'était l'objectif des marins marins
ou j'ai j'étais très jeune alors j'ai
effectivement eu cet objectif là aussi
mais j'en avais un troisième qui était
quand même de me sortir de là je m'étais
engagé dans la marine pour quitter un
ordinaire
et des choses j'allais dire voilà un
quotidien un peu peu médiocre qui me
plaisait pas j'allais pas retomber dans
dans une convention de vie maritime qui
était celle des bordels et des bistrux
donc je l'ai fait bien sûr ça oui
c'était incontournable mais en même
temps j'ai pris des chemins de traverse
et je suis allé rendre visite à d'autres
dames ailleurs et à des territoires que
les marins ne fréquentaient pas ben ce
qui veut dire que très vite donc c'était
un univers trop fermé dans le fond
d'abord il était trop fermé donc je
pouvais pas y rester c'est un univers
d'homme qui a extrêmement bouleversé mon
adolescence qui a même cassé une partie
de mon adolescence qui a pas toujours
été tendre mais parce qu'elle a pas
toujours été tendre et puis parce
queelle a détruit aussi des rêves des
espoirs elle a même aidé à ce que
l'amour un temp soit assassiné oui c'est
vrai on croyait plus à l'amour donc on
allait baiser on allait pas faire
l'amour euh donc les filles étaient
regardées plutôt comme oui un passe temp
et donc il fallait devenir un homme il
fallait devenir un homme comme les
autres et en même temps c assez violent
l'universê oui parce que moi on a essayé
de me pendre quand même à un moment
donné on a essayé de me me flinguer euh
mais par par bêtises par par ivrognerie
par bon violence sexuelle aussi non non
non il y a eu il y a certains l'ont subi
bien sûr oui il y en a eu eu mais moi
non je me suis pas retrouvé le Petit
Mousse du bord giron qui se bien sûr
j'ai eu les marins qui ont été mais ça
je l'ai écrit dans mais ça se cache pas
c'est comme ça des marins qui étaient
àour de moi qui m'écrivaient des lettres
qui me faisaient des cadeaux bon ça
c'est c'est
bon c'était pas mon voilà j'étais pas
amoureux des hommes et j'aimais les
femmes j'ai toujours aimé les dames si
j'avais dû être à ce moment-là j'avais
dû prendre ce tournant là je l'aurais
pris et vous dites d'ailleurs que la
connaissance du continent féminin c'est
aussi un
voyage que j'ai peut-être pas toujours
réussi
mais j'ai
oui vous l'avez dit vous l'avez écrit en
tout cas j'ai dit beaucoup de bêtises
aussi vous savez j'espère que vous les
avez pas not je sais pas ça c'est une
phrase du livre en tout cas donc vous
écrivez dans votre livre il y a eu des
jouissances précipitées des regards
morts mais parfois aussi des bonheurs
avec les rire l'insouciance l'abandon et
l'éternité de l'instant il y a eu des
trésors et des fausses perles des
mirages d'amour et des corps glacés que
dire d'autre oui c'est parce que et vous
parlez des amours de porc qui n'étaient
pas des amours mais des noyard en
secousse c'est c'est très signifiant
pour un jeune homme de 17 18 ans de se
retrouver dans dans ces noyades là et
s'en sortir pas toujours bien mais
est-ce que on est en train d'assassiner
l'amour ou pas parce que je savais que
ça n'était pas ça et c'est pour ça que
j'ai failli être un assassin à un moment
donné ou un autre j'ai failli tuer une
une oui au Japon parce que parce
qu'elle avait réellement assassiné ce
que je pouvais croire de l'amour ce que
pouvait être l'amour et et qui est
d'ailleurs et donc je suis parti et et
là j'ai commencé à avoir une période un
peu délicate dans
l'alcool mal de trucs et c'est le
théâtre qui m'a recadré parce que là il
y a une discipline quand même
extraordinaire que ce soit dans le champ
que ce soit dans la danse j'ai fait
beaucoup de danse à ce moment-là grâce à
une femme qui s'appelle colollette
mineur etilà vous êtes toujours vous
êtes toujours sauvé hein vous avez
toujours senti moment où il fallait une
dame à chaque fois une dame à chaque
fois
souvent une dame qui était la jeune d'c
c une belle dame et certaines dames de
rencontre et puis après après des dames
sur le parcours oui je demande dans ce
livre les dames de nage d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce que ça signifie les dames de N
ah je suis cont de Me posz cette
question j'aiis peur que vous passiez à
côté c'est très très important les dames
de nage ce sont deux deux petites
fourches qu'on met dans sur les plat
borord de d'une barcasse pour pouvoir
avironner comme on dit pour pouvoir
ramer on met les deux rames dedans ou
odi à l'arrière du bateau mais donc il
nous faut les dames de nage pour avancer
mais on avance d'eau à l'objectif donc
voilà je trouvais que c'était une
symbolique assez assez jolie belle belle
jamais vous n'avez été un mari dans le
fond Marie non jamais é Marie j'étais un
compagnon oui compagnon j'ai vécu
longtemps effectivement vous parlez d'an
DUP
per alors ça c'est pas à moi de dire si
j'étais un bon ou un mauvais compagnon
je pense que j'étais un compagnon
difficile oui puisque j'étais pas bien
dans mes basquette comme on dit que j'ai
j'ai j'ai j'avais une grande inaptitude
au bonheur et que malgré la quête et
freiné que je poursuivais mais par
impuissance tout
ça c'est par impuissance c'est parce que
si on arrive à trouver le calme la
sagesse par rapport à à et à savoir où
se trouve
l'essentiel c'est je vous écoute en même
temps je me dis c'est étonnant parce
qu'on a le sentiment que tout le temps
vous avez rechercher justement le cadre
et à être cadré si je puis dire je pense
que très très vite j'ai eu besoin de ça
et beaucoup dans ma vie j' besoin de ça
parce que j'étais un enfant puis un
adolescent puis un homme qui a toujours
débordé dans l'extrême ou que ce soit
dans les jeux dangereux que ce soit dans
les sports dangereux que ce soit voilà
j' toujours débordé jusqu'à
l'inconscience et la bêtise dirais-je
donc il fallait à un moment donné me
retrouver dans une structure dans votre
livre he les dames de nage on le voit
aussi vous êtes toujours avec des
justement dans des situations borderline
avec des personnages qui sont toujours
aussi dans des continents perdus avec
des personnages aussi perdu des
personnes perd au bord de la BIM ou pour
acquérir cette c'était bête je sais
c'était peut-être pas la solution pour
acquérir une connaissance autre vous
parlez d'ailleurs de Marco Marti à un
moment donné je ne sais pas sil ou elle
a existé ce travesti oui ces travesties
qui ont existé c'est trois travestis en
fait mais j'en ai fait j'en ai fait un
mais c'est d'abord une jeune fille
merveilleuse que j'ai rencontré à à
Calama dans le désert d'atakama qui
était sublime que je je filmais des des
prostituées la nuit dans un endroit un
peu chaud et est arrivé cette jeune
fille à la vitre tout à fait délicieuse
merveilleuse bon je suis allé les filmer
le long du mur comme ça puis très vite
par un geste un peu obscène je me suis
aperçu que c'était un homme donc ça
m'avait beaucoup frappé car elle était
extrêmement désirable donc c'était
extrêmement troublant et puis il y a eu
une une jeune femme je peux dire ça à
qui je peux rendre hommage d'ailleurs
qui était une canadienne et qui venait
me voir jouer au théâtre et avec qui on
a eu une relation comme ça
épistolaire de temps en temps elle
venait et qui est morte du du sida et
qui qui qui a servi un petit peu
d'exemple à ce à ce à ce personnage de
Marco Marti ce sont des personnages
extrêmement troublants bouleversant des
personnages de la vie
qui qui qui vous saisissent et qui vous
font aussi modifier le regard sur un
certain nombre de choses c'est ce qui
est le plus important quand même
finalement dans tout au long de votre
vie c'est apprendre à connaître la femme
oui mais justement je me pose toujours
la question aujourd'hui est-ce que
vraiment il me semble que c'est un échec
absolu c'est un grand échec mais bon
faut accepter aussi les échecs
endurcissent et le succès fragilise
alors voilà donc il vaut mieux un échec
en tout cas le couple sur le long terme
c'est impossible ah non commencez pas
là-dessus j'ai pas j'ai pas de réponse
làdessus moi je vois des couples
merveilleux qui tiennent depuis des
dizaines d'années et ça vous fait envie
oui absolument je trouve que c'est
magnifique je trouve que c'est tout à
fait extraordinaire c'est une paix c'est
une grande
paix quoi d'autre dans la vie que la
paix l'amour quoi d'autre vous ne parlez
vous parlez rarement de la paternité moi
j'ai l'impression que que les choses se
sont passées au mieux par rapport aux
difficultés que je pouvais amener moi en
tout cas parce que j'étais pas facile à
vivre est-ce que j'étais un bon père
j'en sais rien en tout cas aujourd'hui
je tente de l'être et je tente d'être un
père amoureux un père vraiment vraiment
amoureux de ses enfants de sa fille et
de son
fils parce que dans votre livre et dans
vos livres revient toujours la figure du
père ça c'est une figure importante
votre père et un père absent père
militaire de carrière avec lequel vous
n'avz presque jamais parlé pas beaucoup
non et à la fin de sa vie un peu plus
mais c'était trop tard parce qu'il est
parti très vite c'est bien pour ça que
j'en parle beaucoup de mon père c'est
parce que ça n'a pas été dit alors je
réinvente une partie de l'histoire
qu'est-ce que vous auriez voulu savoir
j'aurais voulu savoir un certain nombre
de de de de j'aurais voulu connaître ses
souffrances parce que je sais qu'il en
avait il se cachait pour pleurer tout ça
il y avait j'aurais voulu en savoir
évidemment beaucoup plus sur sa vie mais
sa vie d'enfant aussi sa vie d'enfant
pour savoir et comprendre surtout
aujourd'hui comment pourquoi il est
comme ça et pourquoi et pourquoi il dit
qu'il a raté sa vie pourquoi est-ce
qu'il s'en va déçu et et se dire que
peut-être on peut faire un chemin autre
grâce à ça c'est ce qu'il vous a dit
c'est ce qu'il a dit à un moment donné
oui mais bon il était malade aussi mais
je regrette de pas avoir eu le plus de
temps parce que aussi attention c'est
pas lui qui ne parlait pas c'est que moi
j'étais peut-être pas à l'écoute non
plus peut-être pas suffisamment à
l'écoute peutêre pas prendre le temps de
l'écoute hein déçu c'est tout ce que
vous ne voulez pas être justement ah oui
mais j'ai pas de
déceptionune même si mon parcours a été
extrêmement
tourmenté je regrette absolument rien je
pense qu'il était nécessaire pour en
arriver là et je ne dis pas
qu'aujourd'hui c'est je suis pas
Boudha mais j'essaie de vivre au mieux
les moments qui me sont proposés et
jusqu'au
bout pourquoi vous vous avez eu envie de
de parler de votre de votre maladie
Bernard ah oui alors là est vous auriez
pu la terre comme certains
oui ça c'est la c'est écoutez c'est
assez c'est simple c'est qu'est-ce que
je peux faire moi aujourd'hui parce que
j'ai les moyens de le faire ma position
les rencontres que je peux faire
l'argent que j'ai pu gagner dans ma vie
d'acteur donc ça je dis qu'est-ce que je
peux faire moi pour
aider d'autres
à à se prendre en charge et essayer de
se comprendre et essayer d'aller mieux
alors bon ben voilà je fais ce que je
peux là aussi je fais ce que je peux pas
faire il y il y en a qui font beaucoup
plus que moi et qui ont fait ça toute
leur vie moi je je commence un peu tard
mais bon je vais faire ce que je peux
voilà
vous n'êtes pas croyant si moi je crois
que je suis croyant je suis croyant en
quelque chose de de de très particulier
de tout à fait il attendu un
voyage un autre voyage mais bien sûr
faut le prendre comme ça un autre voyage
et j'espère qu' qu'il est lumineux c'est
tout quelque fois quand on vous l'avez
écrit oui c'est le voyage Amélie
absolument c'est ce que disait votre
grand-mère oui vousle les de vous les
deux lignes tout à fait attendez hop
là c'est prétentieux de faire ça de lire
son propre texte mais ça fait
rien j'étais petit assis sur le bord du
lit j'écoutis ce qu'on disait que l'âme
était plus importante que le corps
l'esprit aussi enfin les deux l'âme
l'esprit c'était pareil c'est ce qu'on
disait j'écoutais c'est le corps qui
meurt pas l'âme ni l'esprit disait
grand-mère le corps n'est qu'une
enveloppe sans importance qui disparaît
avec le temps mais l'âme est éternelle
elle se balade dans l'univers là-haut
débarrassé de son corps elle est la
parfaite lumière j'écouté en regardant
par la fenêtre Amélie qui avait 13 ans
et jouait avec sa petite sœur sur le
trottoire elle était jolie avec son âme
cachée dans son corps je ne savais pas
si son âme était belle parfaite
lumineuse je ne la voyais pas mais
Amélie était pour moi ce qu'il y avait
de plus beau dans l'univers son corps
était parfait et elle était ma lumière
bon enfin bref après ça
dure tout ça c'est assez c'est assez
c'est c'est un voyage personnel c'est un
voyage unique pour chacun et donc c'est
une une voix et une quête et une ce
voyage dont je parlais qui est un voyage
vers l'intérieur maintenant un peu moins
extérieur il est il est tout aussi
passionnant si sinon plus
enfin pas croire n'importe quoi mais
mais mais mais la vie n'aurait pas de
sens alors leur vie n'aurait aucun sens
je je j'arrive pas à croire que la vie
ne puisse pas avoir un sens on le trouve
ce sens c'est être j'en parlais tout à
l'heure déjà être donc être c'est déjà
inouï que d'être prendre conscience
d'être c'est déjà
inoui donc c'est une chose inouie que
vous avez faite ces dernières années
pour vous et peut-être que le voyage qui
suit est encore plus
inouï maintenant on va faire silence vé
mental comme les yogi voilà merci merci
beaucoup pour ne rien manquer sur ma
chaîne in mire Duma abonnez-vous et
activez la
[Musique]
cloche